you
the 67th annual Academy Awards is being
brought to you by
JCPenney looks right priced right doing
it right
IBM solutions for a small player
McDonald's have you had your bread today
and revlon revolutionary products for
revolutionary women ladies and gentlemen
Academy Award winner and nominee again
this year mr. Paul Newman
there is an old expression in the land
of the blind the one-eyed man is king
well in the land of film the one-eyed
man is also king if that eye is looking
through the viewfinder of a camera and
bringing all his skill to bear on the
look in the field of the film he is
shooting this King goes by another title
cinematographer and tonight we recognize
five of them for the outstanding work
they have done this past year in
bringing their vision to the screen and
the nominees for cinematography are Don
Burgess for Forrest Gump
and the Oscar goes to
should I go back and do that again no
the Oscar goes to John told four legends
of the fire
thank you very much Don Burgess Roger
Deakins
oh and royzman in pewter Sowinski were
the other cinematographers
this is truly an honor to be here this
evening and I must share this with a
wonderful cast a fantastic crew director
ed Zweig Ed's ooook production designer
Lilly Kilvert all who contributed so
much to this picture thank you very much
okay I figured out how this works when
you win your award you come up on stage
and you just keep talking till you hear
the music